I was actually a special agent with
Homeland Security so Mexican cartel
related did you ever see anything that's
just like crazy one I remember was
border patrol had caught this guy and he
starts telling me about how he's like
The Bodyguard for one of these
high-ranking cartel guys and he was
telling me how he used to get extra
money for every Mexican Marine that he
and what he would do is he would like
slice off a piece of her ear or a finger
or whatever he'd bring it back to his
boss and he got extra money for every
body part that he brought I couldn't
handle that yeah it made me aware of the
evils that human beings are capable of
so nothing really surprises me at this
point but it made me look at the world
for what it really is unfortunately
there are some really bad people out
there it's not all sunshines and
rainbows